so i want to start today with what's
really fundamentally an infrastructure
story but also a story about how
we often sort of miss the forest for the
trees or we end up wrapped up in a
detail when the bigger story is really
the big picture many of you might have
heard about this bridge collapse that
took place in pittsburgh and because of
the timing of a joe biden trip to
pennsylvania it immediately became
very very political we're even going to
look at a clip on fox news of
a couple of anchors there talking about
the collapse and joe biden's
infrastructure bill and uh just getting
just about every single fact wrong but
before we get to that i think it's
important
to remind you guys that when we talk
about infrastructure and the fact that
the us is woefully behind on
infrastructure spending that
infrastructure spending which in many
countries is not political in the u.s is
so politicized and partisan
that we have
hundreds of bridges with the exact same
rating as the pittsburgh bridge that
collapsed and yet we only talk about the
issue in real serious terms when a
bridge actually collapses when we have
debates about infrastructure
it is mentioned in passing hey we have
many bridges that need to be up you know
repaired uh brought back uh modernized
etc
but it's almost like it doesn't really
exist until there's a bridge collapse
and case in point there's a very good
article on new jersey.com nj.com which
points out
nearly 500 new jersey bridges received
the same poor rating
as the one that collapsed in pittsburgh
and this is for new jersey and it has a
map so you can see which which are
nearby but it points out on the
fhwa's national bridge inventory for
2021 482
garden state bridges received a grade of
poor
that's the same rating as the bridge in
pittsburgh's frick park that collapsed
on friday morning injuring 10 people
states federal agencies and tribal
governments submit data to the bridge
inventory on an annual basis about seven
percent of jersey bridges have that poor
grade
27 are good which is the highest rating
and the rest are somewhere in between
each bridge receives ratings on its
decks superstructure substructure and
culvert
etc etc so
also important is that many of these are
railway bridges over which trains are
transiting so obviously most of these
bridges rated poor are not going to
collapse
i saw a comment from a bridge engineer
who has explained
al also you can't always tell by looking
at a bridge which category it's in that
there's lots of bridges that look very
bad
cosmetically but structurally are
actually in that category good even
though if if you or i looked at it we
would say that that's an absolute
disaster
but
there are
lots of these bridges with the exact
same rating actual structural rating as
the pittsburgh bridge that collapse now
of course it probably won't collapse
when you or i or any one vehicle goes
over it usually it doesn't happen but it
reminds us that we have a primarily
reactive economy in the united states
and this is different than in many other
countries
there's countries where you find this
but there's many european countries that
have a different approach in the us
certainly among the right
sometimes on the left as well
spending money before there's a problem
is seen as uh imprudent it's seen as a
waste of money
and often the money doesn't get spent
until something falls down or somebody
dies first it's similar in health care
why make insurance companies cover all
of this optional preventive stuff treat
sick people well no but that's the whole
point the optional preventive stuff
keeps people healthier on average and it
avoids some of that big spending later
half the country at least in terms of
the political reality
uh just doesn't accept that whether they
believe it or not they don't accept it
as a way to actually do politics and
it's the exact same principle here uh
when it comes to these
bit bridges but bigger picture with
infrastructure spending overall which is
when you look at that list and remember
when we just had the debate over
infrastructure you look at that list and
so many on the right and some on the
left look at that list and they go this
stuff it's it's not really
infrastructure spending how is it
infrastructure spending where we are
reacting to a particular storm by saying
we're going to bring all of this stuff
up to new code that's not really
recovery that's that that's something
these are pet projects no it's the same
principle as with healthcare and even
with this weight it took this one bridge
collapse to get people thinking in
slightly different terms about these
things but looking just at new jersey
and you have 500 bridges with the exact
same rating and
it hopefully it doesn't happen
frequently
but it's just a matter of time until it
happens again
a great way to support the david pakman
show is by supporting our sponsors today
one of our sponsors is sheath underwear
the only men's underwear that once and
for all ends the sticking
and the chafing and the readjusting that
traditional underwear causes sheath
creates ergonomic boxer briefs designed
to keep everything separate dry cool and
comfortable
if you've only worn traditional
underwear give sheath a try it's a level
of comfort you probably didn't even know
was possible because it prevents skin on
skin contact this is the future of
underwear stop wearing uncomfortable
underwear that mashes and constricts
wear sheath to keep yourself comfortable
and sweat free the amazing reviews
online speak for themselves people love
sheath underwear it's excellent and
sheath is giving my audience
20 off when you go to sheath underwear
dot com slash pacman and use the code
pacman the link is down below